i would come into church
and preach that god loves me that god
accepts everybody
and i didn't believe that for myself
i was walking around wearing a mask
i'm reverend derek terry pastor st
peters ucc and i am a black gay man who
ministers
so for a lot of people the idea of being
black
gay and christian
are three
intersectionalities that cannot
come together
i was 19 when i accepted my call to
preach in the african methodist
episcopal church
i was the fifth generation of my family
at this church
in its bylaws says you can't ordain
someone who's gay as a minister you
can't attend
perform or condone gay marriage
i knew that there was not a place for me
i didn't want that life i didn't want
the sneaking the hiding
the seediness of not being able to be
accepted for who i was as i was
i resigned
once i resigned i found the united
church of christ
and so today the idea that we're looking
at
is that i
am good enough
when i first applied to be the pastor of
the church i was very nervous and i
didn't think that they would hire me
and i said i'm gay i'm young and black
and they said okay
it is extremely liberating to be able to
come to church to be able to stand
before people and to be loved and
affirmed for who i am as i am without
hesitation without fear and
knowing that it simultaneously empowers
others to do the same
you